I bet money you couldn't find every
Easter egg in Hidden reference and how I
met your father in one watch so you're
welcome I did the work for you I solved
the mystery of Captain's missing
pineapple getting down to the core of
Robin's bull fighting Antics and
analyzing a potential clue for Ted
Mosby's return
this is definitely an easy way to pay
homage to How I Met Your Mother every
sitcom that centers around a group of
friends always has that home base
apartment and I'm thinking about Rachel
and Monica's apartment in friends right
now apartment 4C is that location for
this show it started out as Ted and
Marshall's first place after college
then Lily moved in and even Robin ended
up staying there obviously towards the
end everyone moved out and the apartment
got rented by none other than Sid and
Jesse it was a total score we got it
from this old married couple who posted
it on the Wesleyan alumni group okay we
have to talk about this callback to
Barney's favorite bar game have you met
Ted no no we're not playing heavy Matt
said hi have you met Ted where Barney
goes around and introduces him to
different women and how I met your
father Ellen moved to New York to
connect with her brother after her
divorce and they developed this sort of
wing sibling situation when going out to
the bars or as they like to refer to it
Wing sibs did you catch the Callback
where Jesse introduced Ellen to a woman
at Sophie's party with hey have you met
Ellen Gotta Love A Good callback there
are a few things more Awkward than a
first date especially if you drop the L
word before the dates even over when
Sophie and Jesse had their first date in
the season finale things actually went
really well Sophie ended up staying over
which obviously is a win but when Jesse
dropped those words I love you Sophie in
his sleep the vibe definitely switched
this was actually another callback to
Ted and Robin's date in the How I Met
Your Mother pilot I think I'm in love
with you I would say they never learn
but at least Jesse was asleep when he
did it okay I would absolutely pay an
egregious amount of money for a bottle
of Glenn McKenna if you don't know what
that is it's the brand of whiskey that
everyone would drink and How I Met Your
Mother they would always end up breaking
a few bottles which is a mistake I'm way
too broke for we don't see this whiskey
and how I met your father except for one
instance when Sophie went to a bar that
had it advertised on the wall behind her
there was also another instance when the
captain downed his super rare bottle of
it in one go which was kind of funny
considering how expensive and valued the
whiskey was supposed to be and How I Met
Your Mother
everyone's favorite bartender has to set
the stage there was no other way to
confirm that Sophie was stepping into
the same bar and World essentially as
How I Met Your Mother then to have her
talk with Carl the bartender and
McLaren's Pub Robin's also in this scene
but we wouldn't really consider her an
Easter egg Carl was one who was supposed
to stand for all the fun Robin and her
friends had hanging out in the bar
together and it was definitely the
perfect dose of nostalgia to start off
the series okay but who else was super
disappointed that we never got the full
tea on Robin's bull fighting Antics in
Europe I really thought that was just a
loose thread from the How I Met Your
Mother universe but the writers did not
disappoint by bringing it back up the
story you did on the bullfighters where
you actually got in the ring and got
going by a ball do you remember Ted's
pineapple the one that he found in his
room during the first season of How I
Met Your Mother yeah well we found out
later in a deleted scene the origin
story of said Pineapple Ted stole it
from the captain I don't know if there's
a surge in price for pineapples at that
time or what but I'm here for it well in
the season finale of How I Met Your
Father the captain makes a reference to
it when he says haven't hurt this bad
since someone stole that pineapple off
my front doorstep and not five classic
so I definitely want your opinion on
this one in the scene where Ellen is
shaving Charlie's beard we can see
Charlie reading a newspaper and from
what we find out the arts section A few
years before How I Met Your Father takes
place Ted was still pretty famous for
his design of the gnb building which
means it's definitely possible for
another Ted Mosby high-rise to go up the
newspaper is also the most perfect and
subtle way to drop that little hint for
us it's more than likely Charlie is
reading about Ted's achievements and
could very well show up but what do you
think
okay obviously I couldn't possibly go
into every single callback in Easter egg
how I met your father gives us it would
take way too many hours for that video
to upload I do love the bullfighting
callback the l-bomb drop and of course
the infamous apartment what moments do
you think I should have included in the
list
foreign